The gift of life isn't the only thing the
survivors of Infinity War will get in the
fourth Avengers movie.
According to leaked promo art for the sequel
that's emerged on the internet, they'll also
be getting some slick new suits.
At least, it looks like Thor and Rocket will
and just in time for Halloween.
The artwork in question looks to be the back
side of packaging for an Avengers-related
toy, and while the leaked photo isn't high-quality,
it does give fans an idea of what a few Marvel
heroes might be wearing in Avengers 4.
Accented with red patches, the suits are a
shiny, silver-white color along the torso,
arms, and sides of the legs, and black everywhere
else.
Thor sports a thick, black Avengers "A" on
the chest-plate of his suit, and wields what
looks like an upgraded version of his newest
weapon, the hammer-ax hybrid Stormbreaker.
And though Rocket appears unarmed, the ingenious
space rodent is probably still pretty dangerous.
"What is that"
"A bomb"
"And you leave it laying around?"
"I was gonna put it in a box"
Taking a closer look at the photo, you'll
notice that Captain America also seems to
be wearing one of these new suits.
To the left of the Star-Spangled Avenger is
the spacefaring Captain Marvel and she doesn't
have a white suit, apparently.
Instead, she's seen wearing her standard red,
navy, and gold getup from the comic books,
which we previously got a glimpse of in the
trailer for the Captain Marvel movie.
It makes sense that Carol Danvers would be
donning her signature suit rather than getting
the same outfit as the rest of the Avengers,
as she'll probably be introduced in Avengers
4 as a mysterious outsider, known only to
Nick Fury.
It's sort of like in Grease, when Sandy wanted
to join the Pink Ladies.
She couldn't just show up and score one of
those sweet bubblegum pink jackets she had
to earn it.
Captain Marvel just might have to do the same thing.
Thor, Rocket, and Cap's suits evoke the costume
Hank Pym wore when he was leaping through
the Quantum Realm in search of Janet Van Dyne.
Which makes sense a popular Avengers 4 fan
theory suggests that the heroes who didn't
dissolve into dust in Infinity War might use
the Quantum Realm in their quest to rescue
all the people Thanos snapped away.
So, what could all this mean?
The text in the photo appears to read, "The
Asgardian Thor wields the mighty Stormbreaker
in his battle against his foes.
Rocket teams up with a new crew to guard the
galaxy against an even greater threat."
If this leak is legit, then that "new crew"
line all-but-guarantees it that Rocket is
joining the Avengers — for this movie, at
least.
Thor and Captain America might be Rocket's
closest companions on the team, given that
all three are shown wearing the same silvery-white
costumes.
One could theorize that the trio will partner
together on an adventure of their own.
Specifically, they might be slipping into
the new suits to travel through the Quantum
Realm, locating time vortexes, skipping around
in the past, and stopping Thanos from committing
mass genocide before he even gets a chance
to start.
It would make sense for these three to go
on their own literal mini-mission, much like
the characters did in Infinity War.
That's kind of the only way to build a story
around a cast this big.
Avengers 4 co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo
haven't confirmed much of anything about the
forthcoming superhero sequel not even its
title.
So we can't be certain that these costumes
are real, or if the movie will truly feature
the team using time travel to take down Thanos.
It isn't uncommon for toy companies to create
alternate costumes that characters never wear
in films a toy for Infinity War showed Hulk
busting out of the Hulkbuster suit, and that
never happened in the movie.
So maybe these suits are only for Avengers
4 action figures and not Avengers 4 actors.
And all the ideas about the film utilizing
the Quantum Realm?
Well, they're pretty compelling theories,
but until the filmmakers confirm them, they're
just theories.
Sourceless leaks and unconfirmed speculation
aside, it's clear that the pieces of the Avengers
4 puzzle are slowly but surely starting to
come together, especially now that the movie
has wrapped filming.
As Avengers 4 inches closer to its May 3rd,
2019 launch date and starts its official marketing
campaign, we should get a better idea of what's
legitimate and what's just another product
of the ever-moving rumor mill.